scream has worn many masks for much of
his career he was one of the most
exciting aimers of his generation a
cold-blooded killer who looked for aim
duels because he knew he could click
heads better than anyone they talk about
my one taps there's the one tap machine
not male functioning at all
i want one tactic one fab chicken one
he's got one bullet in it he's three
legs got one bullet oh scream it's their
cheese side where they really struggle
but scream has also been an outsider
because in the turbulent blender of the
french counter-strike scene nothing is
guaranteed and as other rosters rose to
become the region's greatest hopes he
was often stuck watching them succeed
from the sidelines as scandal racked his
region scream missed two majors one from
a teammate's vac ban and another because
the rest of his lineup was punished for
match fixing when the time came for a
new french super team to rise scream was
cast out again and just when it seemed
that his time in the spotlight was over
he found a different one they do talk
about i think it is is one taps right
halfway there takes down one
screen
match right here it looks like scream's
gonna get involved he knows there's
another oh my god
the man can't be stopped
a deal scream bennerly tome was born and
raised in belgium but his career has
been inextricably tied to france i
started cs in 2006 i think i was 9 12.
coming up in the competitive scene
during source scream's insane ability to
click heads immediately attracted
attention 1v4 now scream is a big job on
his hands he gets one onto it said he
gets another one that's three screams
spamming away neil doesn't get the
diffuse and scream and in those early
days no one was legit until you saw them
dominate on lan and scream was actually
removed from a roster for suspected
cheating in source but the allegations
were never proven what scream did prove
was that he belonged in the french scene
and was among the most exciting players
coming up there in source scream found
the beginnings of a career a huge part
of his early appeal was his insane aim
and accuracy letting him quickly one tap
opponents who challenged him on 3d max
he and shocks two of the scene's
brightest young stars looked like the
heralds of a new generation of aimers
while france was competing as one of the
world's strongest regions for
counter-strike source
others were still playing counter-strike
1.6 but both worlds collided in 2012
with the release of counter-strike
global offensive
[Music]
as france's scene coalesced into
different rosters of source veterans
scream was a member of several and he
immediately showed that he wasn't just
good at source but it wasn't until he
joined vari games that scream started to
see the kind of reliable success that
seemed destined to follow his aim the
team immediately established itself as
one of the best in the game and when
they added shots to the roster france's
young duo lit up the scene
by fall 2013 they were considered by
many to be the best roster in cs go as
they had finally figured out the
dominant ninjas in pajamas who would
terrorize the early stages of the game
with an incredible land win streak of 87
maps look at forest coming in here so
aggressively and that's actually going
to be exist to get the kill on smith
scream with one and two screamers on
fire it's a triple kill it's a quick
kill for scream unbelievable now get
right it's gonna get one but mbk will
finish him off how did stream
and their goal was dreamhack winter 2013
the first valve major for the game and
one that featured a historic 250
thousand dollar prize pool while very
games had scored several land series
wins against nip heading into the event
they also attended other competitions
like msi beat it in china that some of
their opponents chose to skip as nbk
told hltv in 2013 that had an impact on
very games's practice obviously it's not
going to be like nip who had just been
pretty much in submarine mode you know
not trying a lot of stuff on games not
playing so many compilations
[Music]
obviously it affected our preparation uh
we're not gonna be as prepared as we
wanted to and that's pretty bad for
dreamhack because it's like the biggest
event of the year a shaky group stage
saw them drop a game to complexity but
in the bracket stage they regained
composure in the end scream found
himself opposite ninjas in pajamas again
but despite their previous success
against the swedes fairy games couldn't
continue their hot streak
they're playing rock paper scissors here
trying to anticipate very games
movements and just figure out what
they're gonna be trying to do into a
strategy that's good to counter it
oh no but scream with the one hit head
shots is taking them down here at b
almost look like terrace or counter
terrorists were able to do it now just
shocks left one versus four with the
p250 valiantly charges forward but it's
not going to happen ninjas in pajamas
takes that thing 16 to 13 shocks
and it is a fake defuse shocks heard
that second diffuse and exist takes them
down and will be defusing this bomb for
real ninjas in pajamas taking another
point have to start feeling good about
this now just going to be shocks match
points all they have to do is take down
shocks and it is game there's flaren
mclaren going after shock shocks takes
him down now a one versus one fly birds
versus socks bomb has been planted he's
got to go for it and he's inside of mini
hut and he takes some down hinges and
pajamas wins this game
scream settled for third fourth at the
first valve major an achievement but one
that fell short of expectations still
scream had a lot to be proud of in his
breakout year he made the hltv top 20
players for 2013 at number seven and his
aim and ability to clutch were already
being heralded as some of the best in
the game oh no a little bit too slow
actually to push this out for us to
exist they get a kill each a great start
for nip and get right comes in it's
green with a double triple oh my god oh
headshot and as the award pointed out 75
of his kills were headshots an
incredibly high percentage even for that
early era and he won more 1v1 clutches
than any other player in the game
screams roster joined titan and their
form continued until esl won katavitse
2014 the next major
where the team didn't even make it to
playoffs i know he's just swimming on
tours live he's marco up inside the site
with the mag seven can he make it work
he's looking for one he's just hiding
behind the box can he pick up anything
off this he's looking for sometimes i
hope he jumps he doesn't get the kill
but coocher picks up a second dosier
coming up huge pick up the kill shakur
get another one smith the last man
standing in a one-on-three as doji is
sitting inside a pit and titans have
fallen the titans are getting knocked
out his fellow aim god shocks left the
roster in april and rising star kenny s
joined but the team never regained
consistency and again missed the bracket
stage at the next major esl one cologne
2014 as the french shuffle began in late
summer scream joined a lineup that would
become epsilon esports considered the
weakest of the three big rosters in the
scene but a storm was about to sweep
through not just the french scene but
all of cs go scream's epsilon teammate
sf and his replacement on titan callie
were both vac banned for cheating yeah i
mean me too me too all my friends my
french friends that they were like
talking about like kelly's cheating i'm
sure
but i was like i was like no he's
playing online
titan
what he was playing titan what the [ __ ]
he took my place and both rosters were
barred from competing at dreamhack
winter 2014 the next major scream could
only watch as his former very games
teammates won the first major for french
cs it's all on get right
it might be the perfect man to have left
here
trying to walk in
pacing himself he's going to spot mbk
first he goes down hell dlc they pick it
up then in early 2015 the entire epsilon
roster was accused of fixing an esea
match against over gaming the team
including scream was suspended pending
an investigation when the smoke cleared
the rest of the roster was permanently
banned scream was the only one found not
guilty but the timing meant that he had
no roster with which to qualify for the
next major at katowice as the other
french rosters swapped players yet again
scream just wasn't in the conversation
the man that some considered the best
aimer of 2013 hadn't managed to show
much on a team racked by controversy and
there were lingering questions about
scream's ability to change his one tap
style to incorporate more spraying i
think it's probably fair to say that
scream was
one dimensional in spite of how
like absurdly talented he was this is a
player who
had
like mastered one tapping to the point
that it became his go-to which is really
the inverse
for
what what most players do most players
default to a spray out of safety out of
like a survival instinct right where
scream it felt like it was almost the
opposite he would commit to the taps so
heavily that he would sometimes forego a
frag because of it you look at the
riflers who really started to emerge at
this time and you know even would later
become gods um you know nico elish you
know these are players who had really
like come up and go and had really you
know kind of been molded by a game like
a version of counter strike in which you
know spraying wasn't to be feared it was
to be you know embraced and and mastered
and i think the perception on stream is
that he kind of never really adapted to
that you have said as well in the past
and some people criticized you for it
said sometimes in your gun fights you
try to one tap the head too much and
maybe that you need to spray more what
do you think about that yeah that that's
actually true yeah
i had this problem in the past but now
i'm
i'm i'm a lot better than this now it
was when the titan roster was picked up
by g2 esports after selling the previous
roster to phase that they started to
pick up steam an angel is gonna go
flying in like an angel
and gets wrecked by smiths smith sends
him straight to hell and i'm really
pleased about that scream just look at
these headshots it's disgustingly
beautiful to watch this guy's aim is
ridiculous i don't care it's against an
eco it's just nice to watch scream had a
sort of renaissance in 2016 freed from
the more structured style of existence
when he was replaced by body but it
wasn't just glimpses of the old scream
either cs go's spray patterns had led to
precision spraying at the professional
level an important skill for any rifler
and scream had changed his game while
headshots were still his specialty he
had varied his approach to include more
sprays all the smokes reigning in mg2
look how close scream is playing you can
see them early on gonna go for the quick
peek that's the bomb down sprays oh what
a transfer shots taco down and cold
sierra and further left here two versus
four
what a heroic round from screen
and that translated to success at the
ecs season one finals scream won the
biggest prize of his career when g2
defeated luminosity in the grand finals
and the headshot machine was named the
mvp there is the smoke that's gonna
basically tell fnatic what's going on is
the b split but there's dennis ready
behind the crate the first round comes
in bites his time but scream will still
be undenied it's up to all the fights
with the up on the sides first shot
connected one more player that's all he
needs to find scream gets the head shot
though one on one for him
looking for that one versus one the next
one in cw's got 50 seconds to play with
but he's just gonna go for it
you know for players like uh scream and
rpk who've been playing alongside
existence for a long time having
struggled to even make it to playoffs of
tournament just make it out of the group
stages and now after their most recent
change bringing in body and switching
shocks to the role of the in-game leader
of the team they not only can get it get
through the group stages they're also a
contender for attorneys and finally
after a really long time for some of
these players they managed to get an
international title under their belt
scream was having a moment he still had
the aim that it helped him break out in
2013 but he also had a kind of allure
that only a master of the game's sexiest
play could pull off they know me as the
headshot machine
they know me from the highlights they
see
they know me from the matches they watch
they talk about my one taps and i think
for me
aiming is so easy it's worth mentioning
that like the fact that scream was able
to play the way that he did in cs go for
as long as he did is actually really
impressive to just walk around one
tapping people in cs go is really hard
two more now
why is
still while scream's level of play was
able to shine his team bombed out of the
group stage of two more majors in 2016.
the closest he had ever gotten to a
major win was in 2013 and unfortunately
it was the closest he'd ever get
as another french super team formed
without him scream was considered for a
spot on faze clan but that spot was
eventually filled when the organization
acquired nico scream then spent over a
year with team envious who struggled to
make much of an impact after that
organization dropped its roster in 2018
scream took what he could get standing
in for fanatic playing on a mixed team
called left out with mike lele and then
joining gamer legion in early 2019
though he was benched a half year later
and spent almost a year riding the pine
and that looked like the end of the
story for scream he was still streaming
and he was still hitting headshots
streaming might have been his exclusive
path forward like it was for so many
ex-pros through tens of thousands of
professional kills a plus 100 1v1 clutch
differential and dozens of what-ifs the
player who had shown such flashes of
brilliance had never won a major but
he was given a second chance
go on
let's go
[Applause]
scream didn't have to give up on esports
instead he could move to valorent so my
expectations from valor and
it's gonna be really high of course
since i'm leaving cs and
i've been playing cs my whole life and
cs has given me a lot
so i expect valerian to
to give me something as well the game
wasn't cs but it was the next closest
thing
in some ways it was an even better game
for scream with the less precise spray
patterns and movement further
emphasizing his signature one taps and
right away it seemed like the old scream
was thriving scream last man standing
bladestorm online
halfway there takes down one
screen
and now he's in trouble suddenly he has
to take the fights and wins the fights
he's still oh
scream just absolutely beheaded nissa
that is gonna leave him ringing
4v3 spike now plan no no spike blonde
scream scream death match right here and
they're playing contact so they'll pick
up the pace
now and it looks like scream's gonna get
involved he knows there's another oh my
god that's third the man can't be
stopped that third kill was ridiculous
scream now doesn't lurk you're looking
[Music]
scream is good for four here what a
fantastic round from liquid as part of
team liquid valorent scream is the clear
veteran but with exciting young talent
like yampi in the lineup it isn't the
end of his story so my new team is a
very young team
we get a lot of potential but we need
we need of course a lot of practice i
have really good teammates who have a
lot of potential but they don't have
much experience so i'm gonna try to
bring my experience to the team and try
to be the best team in the world the
game's first major lan in reykjavik
iceland is just over the horizon and
screen could again be in a position
to show the world that he belongs among
the best players in valorant there are
still more chapters to be written and
it's hard to say exactly how valorant
will unfold it's possible that scream
could even find himself facing old
teammates in his new game soon but one
thing now seems clear the scream from cs
that lit up our screens and inspired us
to embrace the one tap won't fade away
it will echo in the halls of esports
history
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]